I think we're going to get started so
i'm aaron and today i want to walk you
through an into n data analysis using
python that i'm calling but or not hope
you're not into series of a mood this
isn't a very serious talk um so i just
want to start out by saying that as as
far as i know and admittedly i wouldn't
probably know but i am completely human
I've cats I have a normal job just like
everybody I'm a research scientist at
amazon web services and i work on a
product oh sorry i've been instructed to
stand here I work on a product called s3
and prior to that I was a data scientist
in the nordstrom data lab headquartered
here in Seattle or over there in Seattle
where I primarily built product
recommendations for nordstrom.com and
for our targeted marketing campaigns I'm
also one of the co-organizers for the
Seattle chapter of pi ladies hmm and so
pi ladies if you haven't heard about it
hopefully you have by now because we've
been telling everybody but if I ladies
is an international mentorship group for
women who program in python and we have
a really active chapter here in Seattle
so if you're local come out to some of
our events here's some that are coming
up we also have bi-weekly hack nights so
just bring your project and encode with
us these are these are free and open to
the public so PI ladies and Pilates are
of course welcome to our top nights so
come see us so today I want to talk to
you about the internet phenomenon known
as BOTS and specifically i'm going to
talk about twitter bots and i chose this
topic primarily because bots are pretty
fun and they're they're often pretty
funny but also because twitter has a
really rich and comprehensive api that
allows just regular old users to get
access about the platform and how people
are using it and so I think it's a
really great it serves as a really great
demonstration of pythons prowess for
data processing tasks but I think also
kind of show some some areas of weakness
python and so I'm going to talk just as
much or if not more about how I actually
conducted the analysis as the results
themselves so for those who aren't
familiar with Twitter if you're not
already a user's twitter is a social
media platform on which users can post
140 character fart jokes essentially
called tweets um yeah well well the
manual said to open with a joke so this
is this is going to be a long talk it's
distinct from other social media in the
sense that for one by default your
tweets are public so anybody can view
them and secondly there's there's not
really any expectation that you
necessarily actually know the people who
are following you or who you're
following and so you can think of it
kind of more as a marketplace of ideas
where the currency is faves and retweets
of versus something like like your
Facebook another distinguishing
characteristic of Twitter is the embed
ability of Twitter content so it's
really common nowadays to see news media
where tweets are embedded in in the
actual article itself or as in this case
where the I don't know if you were
following this I was where the tweets
are the source of the news themselves in
this the pervasiveness of Twitter across
these other outlets is due in no small
part to the openness of the API in the
ability for developers to
programmatically tweet or access
timelines or get account level
information but the same openness that
makes Twitter so pervasive across the
internet on platforms that are not
Twitter also opens the door for
unwelcome users and in 2009 twenty four
percent of tweets were generated by BOTS
and last year Twitter disclosed that
about 23 million of its roughly 300
million active users were actually
thoughts and so that's just shy of ten
percent and if I I would bet that that's
probably in an underestimate oops sorry
whew
so what are Twitter bots so bots are
nothing more than programs that the
robots in disguise get it there are
programs that can compose and post
tweets completely without human
intervention and so they range really
widely in kind of capability and
complexity so some are fairly inert they
don't do much but kind of look spammy
and follow you maybe they even retweet
some of your your tweets but then they
they can also be quite complicated and
they can use really sophisticated
algorithms to compose text that's really
convincing but either way both both of
these types are unwanted for Twitter
because they undermined their marketing
attribution and and ultimately their
bottom line but twitter has to take kind
of a nuanced approach to how they handle
this handle the bot infestation because
not all bots are the same and not all
bots are spambots in fact some our
beloved members of the Twitter community
take for example Olivia taters here who
is about who tweets kind of in the tone
of a teenage girl as you can see always
charming Olivia taters and when her
account was suspended I think about a
month ago very recently her followers
protested until it was reinstated so the
strategy of and you can see why the
strategy of of just like identifying
accounts that are BOTS and destroying
those those accounts is not going to is
not going to work if we're get if
Twitter wants to keep kind of the
organic community-driven nature of its
platform so today I just want to walk
through the development of a
classification algorithm for identifying
accounts that are likely to belong to
bots and so essentially what we're doing
here is testing the hypothesis that BOTS
behavior is somehow measurably and
meaningfully differentiable from the
behavior of humans we have a pretty
simple experimental design we're going
to ingest some data from the Twitter API
and then clean and process it and then
create and validate a classify a
classifier and luckily for us we can do
all of that with Python
so I'm going to communicate with the
Twitter API using the Python Twitter
module clean and process data using
pandas in a little bit of NLT k and then
I'm going to create a classifier with
scikit-learn yeah create and validate a
classifier scikit-learn okay shout out
to these mineral waters so our first
step is to is to get some data so we're
gonna we're going to develop a
classifier here and I want to take a
supervised learning approach which means
that I need label data I need to know I
need to know ahead of time which
accounts belong to bots and which
accounts belong to humans and in the
past this has been done basically by
grad students so you get a bunch of grad
students you get a bunch of accounts you
send them off and in their infinite time
they they go and they basically apply
like the Twitter version of a Turing
test so they're going to go look at a
bunch of accounts and they're going to
kind of check them out and say like if
this looks like a bot and it kind of
tweets like about we're just going to
call this thing about but the trouble
with that methodology is that I'm not a
grad student anymore and my time has
value now so so so that's not going to
work for me but I've it turns out this
was this was a fairly easy problem to
solve because of my great friend
Charlotte here so this is a website you
may or may not be familiar with it's a
it's a little gym called fiber where for
up to five dollars anybody can purchase
kind of dubious services one of which is
to buy a bunch of real twitter followers
and i know what you're thinking because
i kind of thought this myself you know
is Charlotte the the real deal is this
going to work out for me and it turns
out that Charlotte is in fact totally
legit and in just just over 24 hours i
had 5,500 at the time great imaginary
friends unfortunately i took the
screenshot relatively recently and as
you can see a lot of good but a lot of
good bots died out there so this is
something that Twitter is a twitter is
actually cracking down on
a lot of my my friends have been
unfortunately destroyed so I know so
that's great so I knew who was following
me prior to purchasing all these bots
and so I could unique I could identify
them positively ID them as being humans
for the most part human human like and
then the 5500 Butler 5500 accounts that
now follow me in the next 24 hours I can
positively identify as being butts and
so great I have labels now I know
exactly who's a human and who's about
that was easy so now all I had to do is
create a feature set I need some
variables about these accounts and lucky
for us there's no reason to to turn to
kind of these shady of terms of use
breaking strategies to do that we can
just simply use the Twitter API and
follow their rules and not get kicked
off of twitter so I focused on two
primary endpoints the first was get
users look up and so that's going to be
kind of your profile level information
so stuff like are they using the default
profile picture like that Twitter
egghead default profile colors how many
tweets have they made how many people
are following them how many follow how
many do they follow so kind of the stuff
that you could get if you were looking
at their account page online and then i
looked at the status of the user
timeline so this is their actual tweets
and so for each account in my data set I
grabbed the last 200 tweets that they
made so up to 200 tweets for each person
in my data set so I did all of this
using that so there are actually several
modules for connecting to the Twitter
API through Python another big one is a
tweet pie but I chose something really
simple really easy to get started with
in a pretty literal implementation of
the API called Python Twitter you can
find it here super simple to use here's
an example of what a little wrapper
around a function might look like so the
function get friends IDs that's going to
take a screen name and then just get
pass back to you the
IDs of people who are following you and
this is so simple you might wonder why
you would even bother wrapping this in
something and the answer is because
there are rules around here and
Twitter's not just going to let you roll
in and ask for as much data as you want
all at once and so this is the timelines
endpoint and so what you can see is that
I can only ask for 180 users information
in 15 minutes and so we can't just do
some we can't just simply send all of
our stuff to the the AP all of our
request of the API at once so part of
how I solve this problem is with this
really charming function called blow
chunks which yeah which returns our
generator so what it's going to do is it
the data variable there is going to be
like for example your list of user IDs
you're going to give it that you're
going to give it a max chunk size and
the last example is about 180 IDs it's
just going to simply chunks up your data
into 180 ID pieces and then it yields it
so this thing doesn't actually return
anything immediately it returns a
generator and what I really like about
this implementation is that it doesn't
assume anything about how you actually
end up distributing that work across so
I did something really simple but you
could imagine if you had a bunch of API
keys maybe you had a bunch of bots so
that you could send multiple requests to
the API without breaking those rate
limits you could still use this same the
same generator object I didn't do that
though I did something simpler so here's
what I did so this is this is would be
this is a chunk or a piece of of what
was inside kind of a wrapper function
around this call to the API but so what
I'm doing first is creating my chunks
with my blow chunks a function and so
chunks is a generator object and then I
can use the next method associated with
generators so to grab the first batch of
queries or the next batch of queries and
so what that's really it's kind of like
you've got you've got this queue and
it's all chunked up into 180 ID chunks
it's going to just grab the next one and
then I can take that chunk
that to the API and then I can grab a
beer or take a shower or take a beer in
the shower because i have now 16 minutes
that i'm going to wait before i send
something else to another request to the
API and so once that 16 minutes is over
it's going to go back up get the next
chunk send that to the API and do it all
over again when it finally gets to when
I have nothing else to ask for next time
I I call the next method on chunks it's
going to throw a stop iteration
exception and that's going to break me
out of this while loop and then I can
continue on do some processing stuff so
this is how I this is how I got around I
didn't get around it this is how I
obeyed Twitter's rate limits so this is
what this is an example of what you
might get back so this is just the
example a payload from the user endpoint
so stuff that you would expect so the
name of the account the location if
they've indicated it when the account
was created kind of profile level
information and it's just a big JSON
blob so at the end of that I ended up
with about 8,500 accounts in my sample
size so more BOTS than followers so
about 3,000 humans and about 5,500 BOTS
okay so that's cool now we have a bunch
of data and now i need to pre-process so
the data the what was coming in from the
API was a all a bunch of JSON blobs but
unfortunately that's not a very useful
format for us for doing modeling so we
need to do some processing but the thing
about kind of processing and cleaning is
that it's really boring to do and it's
boring to talk about and it's boring to
look at so I'm not going to talk about
it or make you look at it except forward
to tell you what I did the first thing I
did was basically just flatten out the
JSON so it was so it would be one row
per account and then I did a little bit
of recoding so Twitter
has kind of a convention that for some
of its boolean variables it will only be
non missing if it's true so like was
retweeted will only have an entry if it
was retweeted and it will be missing
otherwise and so I just recoded that so
that things would be so that false would
be represented and then I selected out
only what I wanted to use for modeling
so the payload was was pretty big and it
contains its kind of mint and in part to
be consumed by machines so like if you
were an application developer and you
were building an application that lets
you lets you view Twitter it gives you a
lot of information about like the
dimensions of media that they pose to
the dimensions of photos and stuff like
that that is not that's interesting for
a machine or for an application
developer who needs to render that
correctly but not interesting from my
point of view where I'm just trying to
see if there's anything funny that comes
out from this classifier so I removed it
and only kept stuff that I was kind of
interested in looking at so then I end
up with some beautiful clean data
columnar TS vs and that's what I want
that's what I need to use for modeling
so just as a quick little aside here
I'll be completely honest I don't enjoy
the process of creating visualizations
in Python and my workflow in the past
has always been to export things out of
Python and then plot them using our so
that I can have ggplot2 which is
extremely powerful syntax for making
visualizations but in the spirit of pi
data i did not do that i made these
visualizations using python and one of
the things i'm telling you this is that
one of the strategies I found that kind
of ameliorated a lot of the pain for me
was using ipython notebooks to do this
which is kind of duh because I feel like
everybody's been talking about it
forever but I'm a light adopter but
creating visualizations in the notebook
made it a lot easier because you could
quickly change things and then refresh
in the browser so i recommend that if
you also find this to be cumbersome
anyway so what we're looking at here is
the number of people that the accounts
are following so these are kind of
outward and what you'll notice is that
for humans so the bot equals zero
I couldn't figure out how to make these
meaningful but bought equals 0 means
that they're human for humans humans
tend to follow around 500 or less people
which makes sense there's only so much
you can kind of read especially from
people on Twitter yeah and so and so
that makes sense and then for BOTS what
you're seeing is kind of the opposite
people are following us more than a
thousand of kind of balance there around
1500 so they're falling significantly
more people than humans tend to follow
this is long-tailed so I kind of lobbed
it off so that you could see you can see
kind of these these strange distortions
and distributions likewise for the
number of people following them so these
are kind of the inward direction you see
kind of this really flat uniform
distribution looking thing for humans
which makes sense some humans are really
popular some humans are not that popular
sir humans are kind of bought like but
you don't see that at all for BOTS you
see them really smashed down towards
zero so most bots have less than 40 less
than 20 followers really so you're
seeing bots following tons of people and
having almost no followers so that's
interesting and that's probably going to
come up again a spoiler alert in the
classification portion so that's cool we
could do that kind of with the profile
or account level information but what
about all this tweet data so in addition
to that stuff that you can get from
their profile page i also got the last
200 tweets that they made how do you
turn all of this stuff in to data well i
used a module that hopefully you've
heard about a ton by now called pandas
and the chief benefit of pandas is that
it gives you this data frame data
structure and so if you've used
something like our any kind of like
statistics domain-specific language
you're probably familiar with the
concept of a data frame that makes it
super simple to do quick manipulations
and aggregations over structured data so
that's what I did so let's just look at
an example of how we might do this so
there's a summary of kind of a language
summary metric called lexical diversity
which is just the ratio of unique tokens
in a document to the total length the
total tokens in the docking
it in a doc token in this case is just
as any sequence of characters that we
want to treat as one one thing and so
that's typically going to be something
like words or on Twitter it's going to
be some weird stuff emojis uh right and
so I i computed this for all of the for
all of the the people in in my data set
and before I before I could do this I
took all of their tweets they're up to
200 tweets I put them together in a
single document so I just concatenated
all of them and then I tokenize it so
instead of having a big clump of text
that represents their tweets I had a
list of words and that allows me then to
do things like remove stop words remove
emojis and other punctuation that I
don't want to include so I did that
first and then i have this simple
function to compute lexical diversity so
i forgot to mention it ranges from 0 to
1 so a 0 would indicate that you have no
text essentially and a 1 would indicate
that every word you've ever used in the
document was both the first and the last
time you use it so every word is unique
and it's kind of a measure of your
language sophistication and so here's
here's the function if there is no text
your value is 0 otherwise it's just the
length of the unique set of words in
your document divided by the total
length of the document and what I love
about pandas and where I think the core
strength is is the ability to apply
generic functions like that over groups
of data really elegantly and so that
looks like this here so the firt in the
first line and you can actually make
this all one big one a one liner but I
think it's a little easier to see this
way so we're taking our tweets data
we're just grouping by the screen name
and then you can just apply any function
on top of that grouping and what I
really like about this besides that it's
super easy to read and understand and it
sits nice and elegant is that the group
x is really generic so if you had any
generic set of categorical variables
maybe you wanted to group by city that
they're in you could really just quickly
iterate and swap those categories out
and can
lexical diversity or any generic
function over these groups of data using
exactly this code so this makes it
really fast to do quick aggregations so
here's what those distributions look
like between humans and BOTS so we have
kind of like this almost like textbook
nice normal distribution for humans
centered on about point 7 which is kind
of what you would expect and then for
BOTS again you have this truly bizarre
distribution a lot of representation at
one and then also more at zero so
indicating that for one they're not
tweeting very much which would give you
a diversity of 0 or even a diversity of
one what might indicate that they're not
tweeting very much so if they make one
tweet it's more likely that they didn't
use any repeated words or that they're
just they're tweeting completely random
text so it's less likely that you're
going to have overlapping words or
repeated words if your text is just
completely random nonsense and so this
is kind of this is kind of a red flag
probably come up again so that's cool so
we were able to get all this data from
the API we cleaned it up and then we
summarized some tweet data with a with a
summary metrics so we were able to get
that to one row per account so that we
could join it on to that account level
information so now let's classify so I
use I can't learn to build the class to
build the classifiers it's kind of the
premier again like pandas you've
probably seen it a ton this weekend if
you weren't already using it the kind of
the premier module and Python for doing
machine learning and so since we're
primarily interested in predictive
accuracy here and not not kind of like
inferential information let's just try a
couple different random classifiers and
see which one performs the best and then
go with that one so that's what I did
and what you'll notice about this so I
have three different classifiers here at
naive Bayes logistic regressions kind of
like your regression approach to
classification and then random forest
which is a
bagging tree fancy method but what
you'll notice is that the syntax for
these three different classification
methods is all exactly the same so what
what I'm doing is just indicating which
method I'm going to use and then calling
the fit a the fit function on it so
before I did this I broke my data into a
test and train and identified which
features I was going to use so that's
what I'm giving it so for each of those
I can you really quickly fit stuff and
then in the second line underneath all
i'm doing is predicting with my new
fitted thing so i'm giving it my my test
set and then again my features and what
that predictor is going to do is just
give me back an array of zeros or ones
indicating which class but or not it
thinks it belongs to and so that's
really a really nice that you can very
quickly just the exact almost exactly
the same code try out a bunch of
different classification methods and
pretty much out of the box okay and then
there's this great classification report
here at the bottom which will give you
output like this so this will basically
just give you a bunch of different a
couple different metrics for accuracy of
your classifier and we can just look at
the kind of total precision down here at
the bottom really quickly and maybe not
surprisingly random forest performs the
best in this case so this was really
easy to get to but it's a little bit
unsatisfying because we kind of just use
this thing right out of the box so can
we do better than that and we can and
that's actually also really easy to do
in scikit-learn so using the grid search
cross-validation function just like we
did before we can give it a
classification method in this case we're
going to do random forest because it
performed the best in the first round
and then you can give it a grid of
values to kind of to explore and so what
that is is just the dictionary keyed off
of the the configurable parameters to
the random forest classifier and then
all like a range of values so some of
them only have a couple possibilities so
we'll just try them all some take ranges
of values but we can give this this grid
to the function and then we can treat a
grid search cv just like we were
treating our methods in the past we can
call fit on it and it's going to explore
that space and then fit with the best
parameter set which is really cool and
then we can call predict on that also
just like we were using before and get
predictions and then we can use the
classification report so this is just
not super interesting but this is just
what the the best random force
configuration ended up looking like and
then the the classification reports are
here so we did get some improvement on
the precision between the not
surprisingly the tuned version of random
forest and the default out-of-the-box
random force so that was really fun and
cool and fast and so here's a variable
important so this is basically just you
kind of like your listing your ranking
of the variables that were most
important for making the classification
not surprisingly the friends and
followers count are the two most
important so we saw that BOTS tend to
follow ton thousands of people but they
tend to be followed very little less
than 20 it's kind of a red flag statuses
counts that's the number of tweets
you've made the account age and hours
spots I didn't show this but boss tend
to have younger accounts because they
get shut down and yeah the mean tweet
length and stuff like that so that was
really fun and convenient but i'm going
to posit that iterative model
development and scikit-learn is still
kind of laborious and to uh to
demonstrate why i want to quickly take
you to another world another universe
where the language isn't Python but it's
our and I want to give you a really
quick run through of a the psychic learn
equivalent in our and that's a package
called carrot if I live through this
this talk so but kind of the workhorse
function and carrot is something called
the train function and if you've used
pipelines at all inside KITT learn it's
conceptually identical to pipelines so
what you're able to do is give it some
pre-processing instructions so this is
this is not really comparable this is
just an example but this is a logistic
regression and I'm giving it some
instructions on how to pre-process my
data center and scale I could also give
it a grid to search just like before I
could give it some cross validation
instructions if I had specific
instructions for it then I give it a
method
a generalized linear model binomial link
family and so it's logistic regression
so this is this is exactly like
pipelines in scikit-learn but what I
love about carrot in that I think is
kind of lacking in scikit-learn is the
richness of the output in the
Diagnostics that you get so this is the
conceptual equivalent of the
classification report so the confusion
matrix function so I can give it my
predictions and the truth and it's going
to give me for one the confusion matrix
which is a separate call and
scikit-learn and then a bunch of
Diagnostics about their predictive
accuracy and so a lot of this you might
not be interested in all the time
depending on your context but it's nice
to have it all here but what I really
like about it is that it's super simple
to get the traditional inferential
statistics and diagnostics out that you
would want and this is as far as I know
when Jake's here he can correct me if
I'm wrong but this is almost impossible
to get at us I could learn so if you
develop a model in sight like a logistic
regression in scikit-learn you basically
need to refit it in stats models to get
output like this which i think is too
bad because you're going to want to know
things like this you want to know what
the coefficient values were you want to
know the p-values you want to know kind
of your goodness of fit metrics because
to the extent that these assumptions are
being violated they can sometimes
influence your predictive accuracy but
it's very hard to get both predictive
diagnostics and inferential Diagnostics
from psyche learn and one last thing
before I stop talking about are at a
Python conference is the resample
function and so what this allows you to
do is really quickly compare models
against one another and so you can give
it this list of all the models you fit
so in this case I was fitting at remodel
and a bagged and a boosted tree model
and then I can give that to a dot plot
which is going to just pop up with a
couple different and I think it's
configurable accuracy measures of these
three models and so I can really quickly
instantly compare the performance
against one another this would be really
hard again to do in in scikit-learn
there's just not enough like helper or
utility functions for getting quick
diagnostic so you can move quickly right
now in scikit-learn so I'm done with our
I'll leave you
I'll leave you with a couple a couple
points so if hopefully if you can learn
anything from this talk it's that python
is an extremely powerful tool for doing
data analysis tasks I was able to
communicate across the wire to some
service get some data clean it all up
and fit a classification model make some
visualizations all with the same
language this could be one big script if
you wanted it to be and that's extremely
powerful so for a data scientist for an
analyst anything investing in really
knowing Python I think is is a great
idea but even so I think some some tasks
are more work than they need to be and I
think that is really just an opportunity
for people if they're interested in
contributing to open source to to look
into and especially on the analysis end
I think that there's some improvement
that could be made there and of course
I'd be remiss if I didn't talk about
limitations so unfortunately I didn't
realize this until I began my experiment
but all of these bots are fairly lame so
the bots that are kind of interesting on
mine are the ones that are sophisticated
they they're funny they create
interesting texts and tweets these BOTS
all kind of look like this they're kind
of weird I don't know what they're
saying and they they're just spam bots
these are for sure the ones that Twitter
wants to get rid of these aren't adding
anything to community and they don't do
anything that interesting so they're
actually really easy to find they have
almost no followers they follow tons of
people they have almost no tweets yeah
so they're kind of like my mom on
Twitter and so this is a limitation so
certainly and future iterations would be
really cool to look at those more
sophisticated BOTS and I did some hand
curating of those before I ran out of
time but that would be really cool to
see how they compare and so just really
quickly I want to leave you with some
bot recommendations if you want to start
checking some out so I showed you a
little bit of God tributes before so if
you follow God tributes he'll follow you
back he read your tweets and gets really
stoked about things that you say and
then just like shouts about them and
throws up a tribute to the gods
regarding stuff you said specific words
and so yeah like dog emoji for the dog
emoji God but what I love about this
thing is that
doesn't know anything about this level
of seriousness of your tweets and so
sometimes you might be having like a
serious Twitter conversation and it will
fixate on a word and just like interject
into the middle of it something really
crazy and stupid and so yeah that's
always a treat highly recommend this is
probably my favorite but of all time or
at least it's the bot that I laugh the
most at sea so highly recommend
following this one this one follow-up
basically looks for texts like bro and
dude and dad and man and then creates
like phrases like why over here when you
can bro over here now slap me five so
yeah this one's great men things and
then Olivia taters we talked about
always charming teenage girl bought
funny and then I'd be remiss if I didn't
give a little shout out to a Grateful
shopper who was the bot that kind of
started started me out on bus so this is
a bot created I don't recommend
following raver shopper this is this was
a bot created by a friend and co-worker
who we work together at Nordstrom and he
created this bot on his last week of
work to spam the social media team at
Nordstrom so what grateful shopper does
is basically get catalogue information
from retailers and then asks for product
recommendations because Jim this is
jimbo Landingham created a spot so he
knows that we know that there you know
like 24 year old people at the other end
of this conversation actually spending
time creating these responses and it's
very funny choice their time and so
that's why I group she also spams Macy's
and I think REI and a couple other a
couple other outlets so a great example
of about that Twitter I think wants to
get rid of I hope she makes it through
and so that's all I have
do we have time for questions or any
questions yeah yeah I will I don't have
it all put in one place but I'm planning
on like writing it up and also close
posting a blog post and I'll release all
of that kind of at the same time yes
yeah I didn't oh you mean like when i
manually pulled stuff out i selected the
features mainly by looking at ones i
thought were interesting so the the way
you end up with from from the API is
something that ends up being like 300
columns long and most of the data isn't
really that interesting so I picked kind
of the the things that I thought would
be that tell a better a good story
basically this isn't like super rigorous
scientific work here but I just picked
like the main thing so stuff like who
they were fault or how many followers
how many following kind of the stuff
that you would get the high level stuff
you'd get from looking at their profile
page yeah and then I didn't do much
feature selection there was there
weren't I ended up with about 20 things
and so I didn't do any kind of like
filtering of that before just throwing
it into a classifier yeah
yeah oh I didn't manually label any of
it I had a 8500 accounts and then oh
yeah and then I split it into like about
80 20 test train so whatever eighty
percent of 8,500 is is what my training
set was yeah yeah yep yeah so I did a
couple like to close to this to this
date basically I started manually
curating some of like Olivia taters and
like some of the interesting kind of
artisanal BOTS to include in the in the
sample set and I ended up with about
like 250 or so that I manually curated
but I wasn't able to get all of that
kind of done in time but definitely in a
future iteration it'd be really cool to
look at that especially because we kind
of know the how they generate text so it
would be really cool to compare some of
those like the lexical diversity and
some of those text summaries against
humans and against those types of bots
because those are definitely the more
interesting ones than these kind of spam
ones although these are the ones that I
think Twitter should be focused on
eliminating except from not mine yeah
yeah yeahs in the back
yes so there's a couple typically what
I'll do is there's it's called GG pears
and our and I did it also in Python I
don't remember what it's called but you
can make these big like scatterplot
matrices and so I did all my figures and
seaborne it's in there somewhere that
sits on top of that plot lib but you can
create like these big grids that
basically plot all of the data all the
combinations against each other and with
those kind of plots it's really cool you
can quickly kind of see like where where
things might be happening where trends
are going to be and that's kind of part
of how I also eliminated data from the
set and focused in on a subset of
features but those are also those are
always really helpful because they
typically will give you stuff about
correlation and stuff too so you can get
a kind of a summary of quick
relationships and your data